before we talk about the gaming world
and what we've seen recently let's talk
a little bit about this steam carnival
so you you actually you and your family
actually and others raised funding for
this right kind of like what you would
for a startup well you know I did mostly
advise but my oldest son did the steam
carnival and he is a very talented
technologists and it turns out that he's
got a lot of the the same old carnival
instincts that that I had I don't know
whether it was genetic or not and who
did you raise money from he just raised
money from Intel Capital and and
severally just just raised six point
five million in fact he beat me
inflation-adjusted on my first round of
funding from from Atari so you know oh
it's wonderful when your kids can be if
that's good news that's one area where
you were you don't mind the competition
so know exactly what do you make of the
fundraising environment right on you
started so many companies you've seen
also some companies fail which you've
been very open about so what is the
fundraising environment like right now
it's probably the best I've ever seen it
whether we're talking about pre-sales
through Kickstarter like stuff or
crowdfunding of the various systems and
the A+ offerings that the JOBS Act
allowed I think that there is probably
better access to funding now than ever
before but it's even better than that
the tools are making it so easy to start
software companies and to do all kinds
of things that I think that the
landscape is I we're going to look back
on it as the golden age of
entrepreneurship but but is there you
know is there a dark side to this so
Nolan which is that you know are we
heading back to 2000 territory where you
know silly ideas get
and unicorns are born almost every day
well I think that there will be massive
opportunities for mischief anytime you
can sell pieces of paper for money there
will be some crazy people that think
that it's really fun to live a big smile
on investors based on a good story right
I've always felt that those are
inevitable but I think that it's going
to be small and and it'll be
self-correcting ultimately okay let's
start the gaming something you know
obviously very very well firmly in your
wheelhouse mobile gaming is so big now
Nolan and we just saw this deal for King
digital the maker of candy crush almost
six billion dollars is that out of hand
for for basically a company that created
one al Viet very popular game you know
it's I'm sure that the analysis of it is
that candy crush is making a whole bunch
of money even though it's a little bit
past its prime and as a public company
I'd be willing to bet money that
Activision
earnings will do well because of it and
and I think that that's kind of I think
this was much of financials as a
strategic investment but also the candy
crush people are very smart and very
capable and I think would be a nice
addition to the their portfolio what is
the secret these days I mean you know
people even people say in order for
Activision to really make this work
though you know understanding that
they've got now hundreds of millions of
users with candy crush but but what's
the secrets of making a mobile game work
nowadays and creating another hit it has
to be sticky but it also has to have a
monetization strategy and you know one
of the strategies is you get to play but
you run out of gas and if you want to
play some more you have to spend a
little bit of money right or you can
wait till tomorrow and then you can play
some more and so there's kind of this
trade-off between people that have an
awful lot of time and not much money and
people that have a lot of money and not
much time and you can make a lot of
money on the people who are willing to
pay for not much time or you know plate
a plate pay to win free to play play to
win and that means that if you really
want to get the sort of infini right now
you're gonna have to pay some real
dollars for it and those are fun before
we go Nolan I mean it's interesting the
kind of games though that are now being
played on mobile that are you know so
you've got candy crush my kids love
clash of clans of course Minecraft you
know has been so popular
are you surprised just because you know
you created Atari and you know those
kinds of games that were so popular are
you surprised that those kind that those
kinds of games are the ones that are
being that are that are being downloaded
and played you know I've never been you
know the game business doesn't surprise
me anymore because I've been surprised
so many times in the past and and I
think that there's some wonderful games
so you mentioned minecraft it's maybe as
good an educational game as this has
been created I mean I just use so much
stuff and I mean it's it's projects and
and I think VR is going to be a lot like
that where you can you know travel
through the arteries and then augmented
reality I think is even going to be more
interesting as we as we make our world
come alive in some very interesting way
so I always say the best is yet to come